[Music]
wake up early in the morning press play
and let's get it in cause we rocking
with the fighter
[Music]
are those links for a legal ufc stream
on there yeah what you're doing [ __ ]
says ufc tuesday going starting soon
watch out watch it free now
hey email me every time there's a
pay-per-view oh wow oh yeah
cause people forget sometimes oh that's
love can't be too big
from can't be too big if i forget ufc
261
261 got to see someone in the green room
are we on chen together baby
we laughed at that mask on huh you got
some nerve
awareness in this kind of climate seeing
how many innocent black just being shot
i'm celebrating prussia is the number
one record in the company uh country
right now you said company though
hey company he doesn't work here bro he
own ramadan he ain't eating yet
damn it there you go
[Applause]
is like your college degree though what
does that mean suspect
what you mean you're on that remix
ramadan yeah i saw you eat
twice and honestly once once and then
you ate in
uh naples i said yeah one day so on on i
just
what did you do four days you ate you
ate you cheated in austin
yeah yeah yeah yeah cause it was that
when we went to that time spot and you
went to the it was in the sun
the creole spot yeah right that was it
don't
bless you alex miles you're kidding i
told you that cat that came around
yeah i think it's that dog i'm so
allergic to cats
oh no we kept feeding it yeah you guys
kept bringing around mark was [ __ ]
having a
cat you don't like cats either i didn't
touch it
mark was all up on that okay you've seen
mark of the cat bro he has three of them
oh he has cats he has cats he's picking
up by the [ __ ] neck
[ __ ] well because yeah i guess like
that's how their mom carries them i
guess seems aggressive when his big ass
i know he's got a
they need a mom right
yeah mom gets that tiny little mouth you
got the big dick beaters you grab that
[ __ ]
dick grab that big ass you speak look at
he's like they liked us and like i don't
think so doug the cat didn't like it
when he was like rubbing his back
yeah that big ass hammer dog i'm like
definitely allergic to cats
yeah just like i'm like oh jay's like
outside yeah jay liked that that's a
straight cat will me and jay grill with
cats
oh my parents like oh damn you got
allergies year-round that's strange i'm
like or it's the cat you [ __ ] idiots
oh
i got ricoli in the car ricoli oh yeah
throat uh
yeah big mark harley came to austin with
us join the squad
he joined the squad beautiful you can't
play the recap videos because the music
chin
the music yeah i can just play it
without with audio
do that doug without audio that [ __ ]
looks lit
as [ __ ] squad here squad how good is uh
peter at these videos man he's like the
goat
yeah he's pretty dope he kills that [ __ ]
look at mark
yeah i think mark's a distraction dog
he's a big dude
he shuts the streets down women stop
remember one woman
she he walked by a group they were in
the restaurant oh my gosh you were like
this time
they were literally they were literally
like hitting like hitting the window
like
trying to get his attention and point it
and every time a woman talks to him they
grab
uh yeah everybody trying to [ __ ] mark
yeah air airbag guys girls
everybody trying to [ __ ] martial cowboys
out in austin yeah they're like damn you
got a pretty mouth yeah he said it i
heard it
heard it i said you purdy yeah he's an
interesting looking dude
yeah hey so i think he was a la i mean
uh
he's a la 10 10. la 10 10. japanese
austin he was awesome he was a 20.
mark's either 10 or la 1. like there's
no there's no middle ground
when i show my friends especially girls
they're like yeah me is fine and i was
like oh my god he's weird-looking
like there's no in-between 20. he's 20.
he's 20 in austin i saw it he
he holds 20 in austin people take more
pictures than him than anybody else yeah
i know yeah people
they kept calling him hella mark because
that's his uh yeah
and ig handle haters would say haters
will say oh [ __ ] hell and mark's here
yeah i want him on the road all the time
oh he says he's on his health he's
so fun awesome was dope though right
yeah i had a great time
everything about texas is doing we had a
bunch of boys come through basically the
entire comedy store is out there now
employees managers all the comments we
saw
son adam ray faheem there he's been it
there's bennett will stop by lucas oh
david lucas destroyed
destroyed he was he was so funny man
as well i used to work at the uh comedy
store yeah he came here we saw curtis
yeah david lucas when that girl came it
was like y'all need anything and no one
said anything right they get their basic
ass face no he said plain face
he's just lighting people up that's just
his thing
and then when rose knocked out whaley
he's like that's for coving [ __ ]
[Laughter]
she lost yeah that's her kobe [ __ ] i
was like david
nobody so stupid oh this is saturday
night
all this saturday oh my man made it just
like the drake record brendan got the
tattooed on his leg
oh my god i was i i it took him i got
that
that one hurt tattoos that one didn't
hurt it was the the back one like
the ca on the back oh that hurt dog and
but
like i i i came in because like legs
hurt more than anything my ribs hurt the
most but legs is right up there
so i was all hyped i didn't want to do
it i was like okay let's just knock this
out yeah first like
two and a half hours like oh this is
easy i got this man
and then at some point your threshold
just hits when you get tatted and your
body's like nah dawg
let's get out of here it's funny i told
him how much longer you got doug
because i am struggling damn he finished
it though right
he finished the outlines but then he's
going to meet up with us in houston and
oklahoma to finish it
because i'm doing a full sleeve from my
knee down yeah
that [ __ ] is bro i don't know if i want
to touch my legs
i saw the game i saw the agony using i
know right i was fine the first three
hours i was fine
and then whatever just like that after
three hour mark kit and i was like dog
how much longer do you have he's like
[ __ ] i'm helping you i'm like i don't
give a [ __ ] how much longer you got
i'm good with however it looks right now
this is what i want yeah
um i'm tattoos man before the shows as
well brittany kept saying that stage
looked like a slipknot stage
it's interesting huh yeah but they were
it's a dope venue yeah that late show
friday though i
said this on stage so you're all gonna
make chappelle relapse man
i've never seen chappelle go off before
they just kept they were just you know
they're not used to cop they've never
had
a like a headline comic there that's
done full weekends
yeah so they've never had a late show so
usually the people there it's off sixth
street the people there you know they're
loud talking
i'm talking the most rowdy room we've
ever had in our entire
oh yeah since the whole tour yeah since
we've been touring i think that's
probably the most rowdy room i've ever
seen in my life oh yeah
out of six years ago i think i want to
say for me too that's probably i'm
talking
yelling and wouldn't stop wouldn't stop
it was so bad chappelle was like
shut the [ __ ] up y'all you shut the [ __ ]
up
they were told chappelle i love you he
was like i don't love you eat a dick
listen no i thought about the real i
said i said it did cause the person was
like he was
he was talking to me we kept like
rolling over my jokes
and then i was like hey man you like
just just stop you know what i mean
and then he was like that's texas and i
was like eat a dick
you know i mean it's not texas that's
you being disrespectful
then i laid down for
i said hey i'll bring it back and i
brought it back yeah you finished strong
yeah because then then they were all
scared and they came out there and
they're all scared
i was like damn everybody all right it's
i mean it's just i mean i get it like i
mean like that
sixth street is [ __ ] crazy so they're
probably like oh we're gonna see brendan
on
at vulcan which is on sixth street and
the stream before
he had a string before which like
there's a freaking
massive amount of bars on that street so
a bunch of people just came in and got
like
drunk and and he uh because they started
kicking out like tables yeah
and and it was funny because the first
table i saw get kicked out
is one dude in the group that was
talking and his people were trying to
tell him to stop he just went but he
just
they all got kicked out and they were so
mad at my boy tony hinchcliffe stopped
by
did a set oh yeah fahim did a set too
the whole squad's out there fame was
because they were talking with him and
then uh
at top at the top at the top and then i
don't yeah i don't know what
when i got on they just like they're
they're excited to see you too
you know like they get excited as [ __ ]
yeah
this is different i mean i think this is
this venue's first run at
hey that guy's doing comedy and that was
hard why bring it oh you see that
painting yeah yeah
yeah he painted it like where we were
all up on stage
that's so dope it's hard that's sick
good stuff yeah really dope she feels
common she is good
he's shipping it to me oh yeah it's
going up in the man cave all right i go
up in the new thick boy studios for sure
oh yeah
oh yeah you got a man cave yeah we
should have him fly out and
decorate the walls of the new studio
that would be the movie he was dope he
was cool
he was really dope uh his name is that's
his idea chris roger
did he have like a mohawk uh uh he had
that little uh
that little uh wakanda oh he didn't have
a mohawk now but he he changed it up
well that's a mohawk bro look at what
brendan he don't have a mohawk now he
got that wakanda cut it's like a little
wild yeah yeah
how you how you want me to be able to
tell when he's got a hood on he'll take
it off
oh he takes it off come on i took it off
when i was there
yeah he's great he's all stoked look at
him
we didn't get too crazy on food there
was tacos dog oh yeah we didn't have
many we only had two but they're best
best breakfast tacos i've ever had
granny grannies they're called granny's
granny's tacos
ridiculous it was yeah it was like
flower tortillas yeah
oh that food was a food called granny's
tacos
you know what i [ __ ] up when i when
the group chat i don't have christian on
there
you probably think it's 12 30. oh yeah
oh just realized that shout out to
granny's tacos though shout out to
granny's tacos that [ __ ] was dope oh in
that video my
uh the tiger thick whiskey guys were
there
he was there he was in town doing
something but he also gave me a heads up
the
our labels won a bunch of awards doug oh
so yeah
got a trophy coming before it even hits
the shelves
and whiskey grammys and [ __ ] man dj
brynn all he do is
win okay that's what you did there yeah
let me see that uh
so what you gonna do with this yeah
you're gonna keep right on yeah why are
you wearing that oh my
goodness is that how you messed up lower
is that how you supposed to see what the
ski mask looks like oh just
yes come on you know you were for a
reason
right here hell yeah damn you gotta walk
around with that like that and see how
it goes for you i'm not about to walk
away with it
if you had if you had a grill with that
ooh only reason why i got it i wore it
because uh
yesterday oh i got home with my girl it
was a sign
and i'll be i'll be honest i ain't like
a [ __ ] uh it was a sign that said
yo my boat my ball my ball
python is loose uh call this address
if uh uh unit five if you if you find
it's been missing since
uh saturday and we only have like six
units they see how big it was
uh now it was a picture though i should
tell you this is a grown man snake it's
a grown man's snake i don't get why
grown men have snakes
right as a kid all right
to you guys go through the door right or
the ventilation or the ventilation
system
oh yeah so it's just it's it's six years
snakes really kick it independent
i don't know but either way i don't want
to see them outside lisa's not poisonous
though
it's just going to bite you a pipe yeah
yeah that's right
if he's big enough he can [ __ ] tie
you know that thing was big
how big though you got you have a
picture yeah let's go to a ball uh i
don't
ball pike yeah but they're all sizes you
know like how how scared do we have to
be
yeah yeah what size they say it was mel
see that's exactly what it was those are
the ones that those are the ones that
pretty much everyone like has
that's like your that's your standard
yeah that's like my son's b-day probably
those [ __ ] things and i saw your face
i don't like him no yeah
he got that way with the uh but that
that thing
no it's not like that but it was her
hands are huge
bro look at them [ __ ] hands that is
true
yeah yeah but yeah that that that's what
it was so he's been listening since how
does that [ __ ] even get out
i don't know she's crazy she has a big
ass like uh breaking bad rv
oh it's a it's a woman it's a woman
she's a single single
yeah but she has like dudes come over
and now oh really yeah like so she's
right across the street
she hot [ __ ] yeah oh yeah yeah yeah but
she's crazy
daddy with a piper yeah you gotta yeah
listen you're not mentally stable and
have a pet snake
yeah so you don't think are you madness
is meant to stay oh no you know this i
do dark as [ __ ]
he's the opener for theo
you tell me if he's mentally stable he
still has his own look at that picture
of me in a wheelchair
that's you in a wheelchair i did this
sketch for them it was like we did a
sketch about a christian comedy tour you
look like drake when he was in degrassi
i know i'll take that yeah it looks like
a [ __ ] shady
gofundme page yeah he was in the car
help chappelle get to his feet back
if you don't see the sides of the
wheelchair you almost look like a little
person
oh i do kind of yeah there's some skit
they did
yeah well some sketch we did about like
it was we were doing like a
christian comedy tour or something like
that and we were we've been like he does
clean comedy no no no no it was an
excuse it was just a sketch
and yeah we just made a text christian
for me so so he doesn't feel left out
looks so happy that's how i was supposed
to look i was like
that's been years ago yeah that was
years ago yeah because you look skinny
yeah i still had a
what no no no disrespect but you know a
lot of fans gave me
a lot of compliments over the weekend
you've put on muscle yeah you look big
yeah they kept saying they're like damn
yeah you're like yeah you put on muscle
yeah
what's up what's up dad no i didn't do
that i didn't flinch at them but still
you know i appreciate it for oh anything
new with uh sheila
yeah what's up with that yeah now jay
said we're gonna take it we're gonna go
to
your guy and uh he's gonna craig yeah
he's gonna get out he's the hounds on
greg yeah
so no one no one once you really
scragged though you gotta be ready to go
i'm ready to go
but uh they a lot of fans they keep
playing though like bro
i'm over here in uk i would get it i'm
like man stop it i know yeah that
doesn't even make it yeah
i wouldn't get it man but yeah no no
craig was saying i guess there's a big
market for those kind of cars
it's low like with high high miles and
[ __ ] like that and those
you know that price range like they
can't they they need them so he's like
is it it's because like a lot of parents
buy that for like their kids i don't
know i guess right now the economy is
like people want those high mileage like
small
cars wow weird huh that is when you told
me i'm like what
yeah i don't make no sense yeah and also
i just got a detail you got value in
your
value i just got detail and i uh the
checklist the check engine light was on
took it off
took it off how did you get it all i
went to the mechanic come on
yeah what the mechanic said was he was
like man yo [ __ ] [ __ ]
but nah he uh he literally said uh
something about the exhaust pipe or
something like that whatever that
the the some of my catalog filters yeah
it might i didn't get to let it breathe
so that's why the check that's why i
failed the small thing ain't nothing
yeah so i got it fixed so now it's ready
to go
but it passed the smog test that's the
smog test yeah yeah everything
greg gonna sell that [ __ ] yeah yeah
[ __ ] so yeah yeah and sheila
moving on up yeah exactly pull the ski
mask down because you're moving on
chain cap what did you guys do this
weekend
this weekend i went to supernova comedy
last night
what's that oh this is the uh outdoor uh
comedy show it's
in uh like the outskirts of the west
hollywood
it's a circle stage uh yeah my
mark stevens how did he do he performed
mark stevens it was a big lineup
that's the stage is that mark saratella
yeah it's work sir tell us yes
yeah it was cool it went there yeah it
was cool it was really fun
the only thing is that in the middle of
the show
police officers were looking for people
and so you can hear like sirens in the
back
and then there was a helicopter with the
spotlight like
like just driving around i said it was
on melrose
stevie took you yeah stevie took me was
he did he go up no we were just watching
oh he was just watching hanging yeah
yeah
stevie's just a fan though because
anthony
what's his name anthony anthony mark
circella
no no anthony jessica yes he was
performing
yeah stevie's got that like slow oh yeah
yeah
yeah it was really fun another weird
thing is there was a girl who brought
her dog like a big dog
big fluffy white dog to the comedy show
it's outdoor though
yeah no but it's not like a place where
you would bring a dog there's just
people
it's not like that no not that vibe yeah
everyone's
packed closer than like a socially
distant show i would say
how many how many people was it yeah uh
i remember
seeing i wanna say six seven yeah it was
packed
yeah say six or seven hundred no no six
or seven uh people go up but then
uh it was like uh how many people though
in the crowd
i wouldn't be able to guess i would say
not a hundred i would say maybe like 60
to 80.
it's pretty good for that venue it was
packed yeah oh god i hide myself on
during this entire pandemic haven't done
any zoom or any outdoor shows
it was cool though that outdoor show was
fun yeah yeah what is the stage
that looks like a different vibe it's
dope yeah theo did it so it's great
yeah mark's told me do it but when i'm
home man we've been torn so much i'm
shut it yeah
that is true shut it down we've been
going in going in like chin what'd you
do
trying to get in actually i met up with
my buddy trevor he's the producer
engineer
guy had korean bbq with him and then my
music is going to be on spotify and
itunes and also
finally right oh yeah but
they're mostly just cover songs but
still that's i mean
it's fine yeah come on man he produces
engineers
music or he does podcasts oh no music
purely
some dude was coming from you for your
job out in austin the guy who does kill
tony works there
he's like dog i will move to la i was
like didn't you just move here
oh uh what is that i forget or who's the
guy i don't know
he works he wants a reason to come back
yeah give me
just get here yeah everyone hot i mean
all the comics out there are stoked
stoked for
boston yeah stoked but i'll tell you
what i will
it is lit but i love l.a not like la
it's something like when you land
like oh well yeah
the feeling i mean the feeling just as
soon as i landed oh i love l.a
yeah and then i go and then i yeah but
then i go i hate new song
yeah it's like right immediately
afterwards yeah
also i got into an argument with uh this
guy yesterday i was over chinese chicken
wings
uh that's what i had for postmates uh
why would you argue about some
someone with chinese chicken wings
because he he said it's way better
uh you know you love wingstop right
lemon pepper ah they're all right i like
my girl's wings
they're way better wings is that is that
have you had chinese chicken wings yeah
yeah okay
do you do you he's like that's the top
the best
like who is this guy what type of
training should come with
you yeah you guys are too loose with the
word comic but who he said comic
yeah legit all right he's legit
christian
hey they're gonna text you to pick that
up yeah you know um but
but uh chinese what the hell what's
nested easy he's a white guy
okay i guess i trust white guys okay
exactly so
so i was like bro you haven't been to
wing stuff you haven't been to jt
he's never been to jt's or wingstop no i
don't know no he's
from maine oh no dude oh you don't count
you don't care you don't come no but i
don't even entertain it i had it
you ain't turning the funniest stuff
what do you mean no but that's a real he
had a legitimate do you notice when him
and jay start talking i leave the room
now
yes my brain yeah him and jake and
the dumbest like debates no it's not i
think
well not even the devastation i just
can't believe you guys have the energy
for it
yeah yeah yeah yeah you know jay got
that jake got time yeah we argue over a
lot
everything so everything yeah you try to
argue with us that night
as well no no damn lebron better than
jordan all right guys
i'll be like all right guys see you
later i'm like oh dude
i was watching i was enjoying my don't
watch anything
around them under i mean they just
talked through the entire show
yeah we didn't i didn't even know you're
watching last dance jay's like oh that's
john stockton and he goes into him about
i'm like he's affected all that bro
tv is on for a reason meanwhile it's not
even about johnson it's not it's about
the bulls
he'll give you a great fact and stuff
like that i was like jay no it's not
that's not what
yo jay likes to talk christian that's my
bad i thought you were in the group
chain
oh you're good i yeah i got it i know
that's what i mean it's all good
i sent to everyone but you that's all me
dog hey
it happens though hey stevie would have
loved
this airbnb we had because there was a
bunch of guitars
oh oh he'll serenade us at night ooh
with that voice yeah that silky voice
thinking yeah
i'm gonna send it to chin oh you got it
i kept that y'all were jamming oh yeah
he
bro he he asked me to play this same
song and that's one of my favorites
you'll see
you'll see it uh is it the dave matthews
band one
no no no no no one can play too hard i
can't do it yeah i can't play dave
matthew no one can play david
i mean the guitar was like this little
it was like a little kid travel spanish
guitar
okay it was like for little kids like
ukulele
no no
you tried you know sometimes when you
i i still got to give you your you know
cause you tried because i know you don't
know guitars
yeah but you know that ukulele is a
guitar
sorry are you going my friend did you
send it to him
yeah i sent him oh yeah no yeah he asked
me to play this song every
night it's it was at the point that
it's one of my favorite songs too y'all
were just a song y'all were jamming it's
a hard song to sing because that dude
sings it very
i know but she was a user
was playing the drums on his legs oh
yeah he was because you're playing
nirvana uh-huh that's playing some
nervous i wish i could rock out like
that
i know the songs but i can't rock out
like that you can you got the voice do
you got the voice you got a voice
for some of the songs that jane's
addiction i don't oh that's a yeah it's
a tough one
do you get it yet no no really you're
not an airdrop
you got an air dropper anyways as jane
says
but the chappelle version yeah
what's the difference between the
original and the chappelle version the
voices
yeah the voices it was to the point that
i never heard the song i was like oh
chappelle killing it oh yeah oh so if i
listen to the real version and i
probably heard his i was like do you
know the song
christian me neither really after this
weekend i know it
that's how much they what song is that
what do you listen to
like uh now yeah um i listen you listen
all the now cds
no like no that's what you [ __ ] like
though
now i'm 96. he's 22 bro now that was you
know
jackson jackson five come on
uh i listen uh like pop smoke mac miller
uh track connection i'm gonna go all
over the place um oh god
22 g's like he's not big at all um do
like just like really like right like
rap mainly
damn listen to pooh scheisse uh a couple
songs actually yeah i thought you're
number one in our country you have to
number one or what he did number one
number one in the country yeah
on itunes online over here
really i don't think so well what hold
on he had that wave
yeah he didn't know don't get me wrong i
do like who scheisse but i didn't know
he was number one
yeah it's still not come through chin i
don't know okay sorry dude it's okay why
don't we just have a live performance
oh [ __ ] that's not a bad idea what do
you say when we have a live stream
no we never bring guitars anymore huh
yeah what happened
i don't know man it's not coming through
what can you do
it wouldn't not even air drop damn
all right jane says
i'm really with sergio
what happened to that band oh here it
goes i saw them live
came through thank god oh cause i was
like that's not what he sounded like in
the airbnb that was awful
the guitar sounded more legit yeah know
how to sing with guitars i was about to
turn the uh
simon like oh that was dreadful oh you
were i missed simon on american idol man
they're too nice
yeah they don't you gotta have a
ruthless person you need someone who's
real you have
everyone's too nice too now even when
they do bad like you know it was good at
times
i bet your next performance can be
fantastic bruh what happened to shane
bring shaming back well i don't know in
his culture you can't though
you don't say social media does look
what it did for me
shaming's all over social media yeah but
they don't get paid for it like unless
you have a job and you like yo you
killing someone but that's why charlotte
ain't so big
yeah that's true but also he still gets
slack
as well like slack white sleeps in his
mansion yeah
he don't get he gets slack you're right
you're right i mean i mean he
well you know i'm with you is that
famous and get slack i'm with you i said
i i don't know i mean charlemagne still
rocks it
that's what i'm saying yeah it doesn't
seem to bother him at all
but also show off how many chardonnay's
out there you
you heard what he just said his opinions
don't your opinions don't bother him
imagine like people american idol it was
like ooh online and stuff like that
they're kind of like oh i am being a
little mean
and stuff like that you know what do you
mean like the mentality
hey why are you being mean to that
contestant yeah bruh
and they were casey that's what i was
supposed to do about this i'm a
professional singer
simon or or what what is simon kel's
background
uh producer who is like biggest bands in
the world so he knows like talent
exactly so like and he'd be like yeah
he'd be like that was dreadful like that
was not good man you had to do better
yeah because when you're just
unrealistic it's not good no i'm with
you you got to hear [ __ ] like
that you downloaded chin yeah sir [ __ ]
oh it is great
let's take a little break from the
shenanigans because guess what it's time
to say goodbye to stressful student loan
payments and take charge of your future
with earnest earnest offers
low rate student loan refinancing and
you can check your rate risk free in
just
two freaking minutes with earnest you
can get flexible
payments and you can pick your loan term
super easy by refinancing you can reduce
your loan terms save money
or combine multiple loans into a simple
monthly payment
if you have questions you can even talk
to a real person
at ernest for help is it time you stop
feeling overwhelmed by student debt
earnest is offering you guys a hundred
dollar cash bonus refinancing your
student debt
at earnest.com fighter terms conditions
play
again that's earnest dot com slash
fighter terms condition apply and you
guys get 100
bonus not available in all states terms
conditions apply
visit earnest.com for more details terms
conditions supply earnest
student loaning financing made by
earnest operations l-o-c-n-l-n-m-l-s
number one two zero four nine one seven
california finance and law license
number
six zero five four seven eight eight
three three second street suite 401
north san francisco california
94107 visit earnest.com licenses
for a full list of licenses again that's
earnest.com
fighter and you can get 100 cash bonus
this is like one in the morning by the
way
[Music]
it's a nice song
[Music]
see how high it is
[Music]
just yet justin was like hey dawg that
note
chances
that's all i gave up jane says because
people don't let me live my life when
i'm singing
or like i would have gave the whole song
but justin started talking [ __ ]
he was like mr clean teeth he get clean
teeth and now he can talk about
different
acting all different got his own hotel i
was like all right dog yeah he didn't
stay with us did he
yeah he was doing his own thing he's
doing his own thing good for him living
his best life
shout out to him he told me he said hey
dog when you was uh
when he was out on stage man i saw you
you know getting
you know ruthless and stuff like that
you know i had your back he's just
like justin he was like you won't let
you [ __ ] you guys
i was ready wait for what like johnny
for what justin
he's the last person nothing's better
than
see just inside a gym yeah we brought oh
we brought him to on
it yeah go to go to his instagram and
look at the picture of him next tomorrow
he's like malik at barnes and noble he's
just like
looking around bookstore slowly like
grabbing things
that's a good idea i know yeah he took
the kettlebell he started doing this for
like five he's doing the kettle no he
started doing this
i feel like mark had a video of him oh
yo you want to see a funny video go to
uh
uh my ig someone said justin's abs look
like they're melting
hey look this is what we did on top of
the uh when everyone was getting
tattooed
this one we did the ski challenge
i am obsessed with this watch this what
is this it's the ski channel bro i was
dying music
look at your brother you guys got jay
acting like an [ __ ]
that's what they do on tick-tock yeah
but now we just like
upped it but this is it's a ski
challenge dance with young thug hottie
song right now oh my gosh
steph is [ __ ] he'll start feeling it
he didn't want to do it until justin
like jay get your [ __ ] together
he started dancing he started dancing
i'm obsessed with jay dancing yeah
you have more rhythm than your brother
oh yeah yeah for sure yeah you and your
brother dance similar but you're much
looser like you can tell he's
uncomfortable yeah you have like really
she's uncomfortable with everything well
he he
listen this is what jay said he was i
was like how's your ski challenge he was
like
it's not it's not stiffer than jake's
but looser than
kevin hearts and did you see yeah
because kevin hart he was loose
right yeah drake was so stiff oh draco
oh great
yeah they're saying jake but drake don't
miss yeah he missed on that dance oh
yeah yeah
he missed it when he's trying to be
funny
right don't forget ladies don't forget
your boy oh yeah
don't forget about your boy everyone's
walking away though
he goes hey get my phone up get my phone
out from the phone he goes you know my
code come on man
and then he goes it's not working sorry
no music i'll do it without music i'll
do it obviously
he takes a deep breath
and the funniest is chris brown like
trying not to laugh
i love that video drink is great anyone
watch the oscars last night
no no i think that [ __ ] was produced by
trilla that [ __ ] was
awful oh whoa it was so low but i
watched it oh yeah yeah i love that i
gave it a chance
i gave it a chance it's tough because
you got to realize
i know we're gonna make fun of hollywood
being so woke and they try to go so
far left whoa whoa yep no makeup that's
fine but the thing is
a huge night no makeup it's fine
yeah that's fine that's where the oscars
are at these days
you look like the ghost from the movie
far left anyway so
um yeah it's just it's just the
just like such an old platform man like
trying to figure it out it's just
awkward the whole
time the production was low budget never
heard of 99 of the [ __ ] movie that's
what i'm saying that's all
they should have had little rel host the
host the whole thing no real host
yeah no they had them do like this
comedy bit like you give like
celebrities mics and they they would ask
some questions about the oscars and no
one knew what the [ __ ] he was talking it
was so awkward but it was funny
uh the monologue like no no
he was like what's up i'm little you
know and it was like you know i'm asked
a few questions like
you know they'd have the dj you know the
famous dj from the roots play you know
oh
like what song is this from did it win
an award anything
it was like so they were like trying too
hard to be like we're hip we like black
people
no we like black people this love was
the d i was on a drug
yeah oh he's a dj oh he's a dj oh yeah
from the roots
it was just it was just like low budget
i i bet
the lowest ratings i saw it trending but
they said pinocchio i guess pinocchio
had a live
action of pinocchio the whole thing was
a [ __ ] [ __ ] wait it literally looked
like trilla dude
we'll try it talk about it ah
that i just saw it on twitter uh
it was just it was weird damn the only
movie i saw that was
even nominated was sound of metal you
would like that movie
i don't know that movie well i heard
that was really good you can watch on
amazon
what is this great movie
or loses his hearing right but he like
trained his ass after so he looked like
a drummer he's like shredded but he
knows how to play the drums
you would love it oh wow good and what
was that uh
norman land what was that no mad land
yeah
did you think of that one no man because
it's clear just trying too
hard man with that asian woman yeah yeah
it was just
it was it was weird and then and these
actors think like
you know like everyone gives a [ __ ]
about their agenda
it's like dude get your award get the
[ __ ] off saving cancer and [ __ ] it's
like dude
you're an actor chill
and they're just saying it should just
it just seems they're doing what they
think oh they people won't relax it
likes often
nothing's real they're fake their jobs
being fake so
nothing is real nothing's real i don't
think i've ever ever think my agents
told him before like hey make sure you
mention
i'm sure the team's like hey make sure
you're talking about they're like pr
channels
make sure you talk about george floyd
you know yeah all right
oh it's just it's just it's just all
it's inauthentic
man they're really trying and it was
like low but the thing was a [ __ ] show
and i like the oscars yeah
didn't uh didn't last year's oscars uh
didn't they
all the actors that were in the oscars
do like a uh promo
of them all apologizing or something
yeah for like their white privilege is
great that was last year it was
fantastic
i didn't see that video it was yeah it
was it was like you're on twitter more
than me but you know
that's it it was they all got lit up
they did yeah because it was all it was
it was like a black and white video
it's great they're all like wonder woman
was on it i'm sorry
bro are you serious bro it was out of
crying it broke
is it so he got lit up so bad for it
like even black people were like please
stop doing this
it was so much what i tell you anytime
you see a white person in the airport
with a blm mask on
they did some racist [ __ ] back in the
day
you're not racist you're not that loud
about it they're always the most guilty
yeah all right right here the top
2016. no now you said last year no it's
black and white
oh no there it is i take responsibility
oh that's what it is
oh for the uh naacp oh he was the best
i take responsibility hollywood stars
they got roasted bro he was the worst
one
he was oh my from breaking bad number of
hollywood stars pledging to take
responsibility you know how
no she's from american horror story
she's from a lot of she's huge yeah yeah
she's huge okay
it was so brutal
they're just so out of touch like so out
of touch
take responsibility he's my favorite
i take responsibility he acted turn it
off
turn it off i take responsibility
for every unchecked moment for every
time it was easier to ignore than to
call it out for what it was you but i've
seen frozen are you not so
justin throwing man he's my favorite
he's the north star for fashion
what are you doing every blatant
injustice no matter how big or small
you're right here you're good she was
reading
yeah she was every time i explained you
have red hair you're good
you're just checking out which ones you
have red hair you're good
black people are being slaughtered in
the streets killed in their own homes
these are our brothers and sisters our
friends
our family we are done watching them die
we are no longer we will not
enough is enough i will no longer allow
an unchecked moment
he's reading something oh for sure
they all are stereotypes i'm not gonna
allow your eyebrows
to carry on like this doug they're doing
a self tapes
i
but they thought this was gonna be like
a good thing dude even though even the
far left was like this ain't it video
games
with your nephew should not be a death
sentence shopping in a store
should not be a death sentence
business as usual should not be
life-threatening all right this is too
awkward yeah
i'm done you can hit pause it's funny
it's only two minutes long but it feels
so long
oh it's only two minutes yeah how are we
at now
[Music]
we can turn the tide it is time
to take responsibility call
out hate the best performance you've
ever had and take action
bro that was the i take responsibility
there you go
there you go what's that ski man i take
responsibility dog
put this ski mask on so sorry i'm so
sorry
what what racist [ __ ] that those actors
do that way they're like dude yeah i'll
do it
yeah because anybody else i'm not doing
that [ __ ] honestly
they stepped up quick oh yeah there's ah
i do it how many times i've used the
n-word where you feel like you need to
do that
that was awkward oh i've never seen that
video i've never watched you you've
never been oh
they got uh
almost career ending for someone chris
and bella lucky she [ __ ]
in frozen oh yeah yeah and she's a
frozen yeah she's the main voice
she's elsa i think oh got it anna
yesterday
i didn't know that i'm sorry kristen
bell oh it's hilarious
some of these actors i haven't seen
since then for real
yeah like that guy who said i had the
best performance he does a lot of voice
over stuff now
he's doing a lot of work he's breaking
bad money he's like yeah he does um
he was just doing bojack horseman for a
while too like
on netflix three seasons yeah so the
schedule is obviously
pretty wide open so with the you know
breaking bad's over and but they but
they have it on netflix
and he gets paid oh yeah before if
you're getting on netflix
i still get paid i think it depends on
their contract
got it depends on their contract because
they have never i'm pretty sure they do
well but that was dave chappelle's
problem like he got paid for connie
central and coming central sold to
netflix and hbo
and chappelle didn't get paid because
comedy central paid him for his work
for creating that show he signed that
deal that's all right
that's what it is like i wonder if it
depends on contracts yeah
hopefully they are but yeah cause that
was i mean [ __ ] massive show
yeah breaking bad it was huge you guys
all watched it i've never watched it
i watched one episode was like i'm sad
people love it though but i was like all
right
you know his wife cancer he's selling
drugs getting upset
i don't know what it is i should
probably give it another chance yeah
i it takes me a little bit to get into
like drugs three episodes
drug shows yeah it takes me three
episodes like the first two i'm like i
don't want to do this my third one i'm
hooked
is it like slow start right all of them
are slow starting
but i've watched uh you [ __ ] seven
times oh yeah don't you
on the road at night when i go to my
room i watch the same series
yeah every night because you know it's
going to be good so you're not like
if i miss it like if i miss parts if i
if i'm like trying to fall asleep i know
where i'm at
like it you know what i just got into
because you you brought it up on the
show you know what i just got into
60 days in oh great joe oh there you go
great show
i'm on uh are you on the arizona one ah
no i'm on the one the first season who
hollered all these daughters in it
apparently
that's muhammad ali daughter yeah what
oliver yeah
miriam she's the first she's miriam yeah
the youngest one
yeah i'm not gonna lie it made me want
to turn off the show any time she was on
camera
you know i don't want to be recognized
for being muhammad ali's daughter
literally every time she was on camera
the first thing would be
out of her mouth would be yeah muhammad
ali's daughter i don't want that to
really affect it she's married though
all right i haven't done it if she
walked in here right now and dropped off
you were pizza
oh yeah no i just know cause you could
but six days in
if if you pay your million dollars i
could do it i'm not gonna do it for
their
30 grand oh yeah they get 30 grand yeah
i couldn't do that for 30. if there was
like a huge
like pot at the end i could do it
because i'm like damn only 60 more days
and i get a mill
the thing about it you got the potential
to get your ass whooped but no one
really gets hurt
and at all i can always just give them
the sign like rub in my chest and then
get me out of there
if she oh yeah yeah yeah they do they do
no they do the shoulder they show them
like this
yeah and then they come get them yeah
because they know the sign if you look
at the camera
and uh also with my training i feel like
i beat up 99.9 percent of the prisoners
yeah you don't you would be the one i
know that one big dude that everyone was
scared of
but the problem is is the the gangs like
you have to join the area nation
from being racist yeah but then they got
their channel
they're hard about like uh they were
talking about it you got to pick a side
because where there's
that white dude my boy he goes man i
want to roll with the the blacks
that's how i would be yeah because
that's all he hung out with that's how i
would be and then i get beat up and then
i go to the yard i gotta pick a side
but if it's one on one sign me up but
all of them i'd be in trouble one on one
you're good but i have to put
ten i don't like me like may hear this
[ __ ] the baby [ __ ] this is horrible
i'm like he's got a rotation
can be right time you know right time
man you can't just like
shout out all right how about we get
this swatch get that tattoo like
[ __ ] dude i'm allergic to needles dog
yeah let them know that i'm telling you
one of my one of my boys uh hopefully
you joined the latin gang
they seem the most popping and they
control [ __ ] they'll find out
yeah you're right they'll find out they
find out i'll just get in a real tan
like a real dark tan so i like super
mexican yeah shave my head
oh okay that's the move like aaron
hernandez that's the move that
is the move one of my boys he uh
he went in white dude that i uh 68
no no he went in because he had to go in
uh broke the law yeah he broke the law
but he i think he did i can't remember
how long he did
but uh he came out he had the
swastika that no the uh ss or whatever
oh he had to do
he was only in for 30 days no he wasn't
in there for 30 days how long was he
crazy
i think he was in there because your
friend's in for less than 90
days i think it is
just enough for every day
to do it my friend went in for two days
dude they forced him to get white power
across his chest
he wasn't even arrested he was just in
the drunk tank hey your friend never
liked you
that ain't your friend man he write
letters already
you know i've been in there for two days
uh no yeah he i think he did like six or
seven years
oh yeah yeah yeah i'm getting all sorts
of places yeah
uh because that was all you got it
that's who protected him
yeah yeah you need that protection you
got him doing whatever he's like dude
you give me six days in 30 days and
somebody hold my pocket
run my feet at night i'm like damn
friend got gay
real fast right that's what you
automatically taken
hell yeah it's just yeah men might be
gay
you're only in there for 30 days bro you
don't like your feet rubbed
nah i'm good i wouldn't want to do
anything about prison i do scare
straight
i was scared straight i'd be like too
old for that dog yeah you two are yeah
right no i'm talking i'll be one of the
prisoners just yelling at the kids oh no
you're not
not scary enough yes what are you
talking about get your little ass at
school that [ __ ] was scary isn't it
you ever seen some of those kids that
fire back at those real thugs yeah and
like
those kids would light you up doug some
of them were gay did you see this big
dude that make that
made that uh he made the racist
uh kid shave his chest head he said grab
the comb
grab the cone shave my chest there
didn't [ __ ] she was like
i don't get how that's going to scare
him out of crime but
you saw that yeah yeah waking up
after shaving that man's chest
and he was like you gonna shave it on
thursdays pointing at another kid
all right that's my stuff they should
make him do some real [ __ ] man yeah like
what
suck dick shank somebody i mean they
can't do that on camera yeah they can't
do it
they feel me this is this is uh this is
scared straight it's children as well
yeah
dude if they're over 18 it's scared
straight x-rated you should have seen
the girl that swung at the cop
i've seen that you saw that one did you
see the one she was like hit me what you
wanna do you wanna hit me you wanna hit
her and the girl [ __ ]
she landed a solid one i don't know if
she landed but there's a there's another
there's another girl who the
is females again the inmates were trying
to scare and she straight up fought the
other inmate
and you beat her ass oh word yeah some
of those kids those baby kids don't [ __ ]
around those babies like i can't wait to
get in here
i can't wait to get here oh they heard
it was funny yeah some of them aren't
like that
they can't wait to get in some are down
because that's what they hit that's what
they heard
you know growing up i got homies in here
yeah i know that god damn girl
you know like chill ain't that serious
he's trying to scare you yeah he's
supposed to scare you
yeah i don't think you could do it
though what no it's not for you mountain
yeah
you're too nice you do yeah you're right
that's like me trying to do i'm really
nice
you were scared i think you scared the
kids you got that you got the physique
you could scare boys sure you you scared
out homies on friday what homies though
our friends was like bro i think
chappelle ready to go
oh yeah there he's been to have this
overall
he had one strap and then he was oh yeah
he was saying because he had overalls
he was like man hopefully i have to
fight his [ __ ] overall
i was like nobody's fighting no one's
just a rowdy crowd
he literally strapped up yeah yeah yeah
he had him like get him
[Applause]
he said he saw me from the screen in the
green room he said that body language
don't seem right
and then he walked out there he was
trapping up ready
i'm like no one's gonna fight and
there's justin of all people i'm like
dog
you think i'm gonna call you for a fight
about justin's like hey man after
working out with us he's like i hear him
uh talking about anavar
uh
man i would start lifting first because
you just don't take anavar and get swole
man because i think you have to start
lifting and yeah
he has to go consistently if he did he
he
like yeah he's like he'd get shredded he
would get so shredded
and he looks like he could put on muscle
maybe no
either way he'd lose that as a body type
i mean he doesn't do [ __ ] now and he's
got it do you see what he eats his
body's not
terrible for the way he works out and
what he eats his body's not awful and he
drinks like the worst sodas
he's like sprite and [ __ ] and fanta
fanta or whatever and all that [ __ ]
though
he just he we just played he just played
basketball that's how you just stay
like somewhat in shape yeah just by
playing oh playing basketball
i mean i guess that could help mm-hmm
but i mean if he
if he wants to build or whatever like he
yeah he thinks anavar is the answer like
you just gotta start because mark was
like yo i can see you big and
oh like he was like all right cool yeah
yeah marcus said you're a drunk i'll
give you an encouragement yeah
he will give you the encouragement and
he'll break it down so thoroughly mm-hmm
he believed in justin but as far as like
justin like bagging up like getting big
he's not doing that
fighting he's not doing that like i
remember was in the j-spot
and it was about to be a fight
and justin i was riding i was passionate
aside and
they were just talking loud and then
justin look at me let's go
you as if you go with me uber back hey
like he was so serious you know what he
might be able to fight
justin that's a lot of talking to the
wild card no i don't think he has a lot
of i don't
know we're not talking about he doesn't
seem like that guy no
he always talking about he ready well
like when we go inside like when we go
through the hood whether we're in tampa
oh yeah we're we're actually where we're
where we're at thank you justin
and mal get the most nervous wait no
wait no no mallet yeah get more we
when we were in uh nashville and i i had
to go to that barber shop
that was in the hood yeah you took your
watch off i took you watch it i'll watch
you
but i stopped trying to cover your shoes
up with your sweater christian we went
to
he went to hood barber shop right so
justin i had the rolex on and all that
justin took it off
immediately right chappelle is in is
they sitting all on
side by side like this he's like i ain't
got it i ain't even gonna hit him they
sitting side by side right
i'm outside with the killers and
everyone on facetime
with my girl the quick what did i not go
outside did i not go outside
i like how you had a single christian
now because he's the only one who hasn't
heard the story and the only one that
might believe you no no
it's believable because it's the truth
chappelle getting his hair cut
justin is i'm outside steel he's looking
back at me like all right
all right i'm not going to save you so
again who was scary justin
chappelle said that you hid your watch i
did not hide my wife i don't know dude
no he hit him
the reason the reason why the reason why
chappelle said it because justin made a
joke
and then he was like oh yeah it does
sound like that and then here's the
thing that was waiting outside for the
uber i went inside of sally's
i was talking i was comfortable all
right that's why come on man
i'll tell you who's down to fight at all
costs is brian count
oh yeah yeah dude like when like when
that time where the hell's angels are
like let's get the [ __ ] out of here he's
like nah [ __ ] them like
bro i don't want these problems man oh
didn't you almost have my balls
you almost got a fight across the street
with some some homeless guy was like
yelling at a lady he was like down to
fight
i was like what's wrong with you doug he
got he got that 20 year old if you want
someone who's down
yeah counts down yeah i love that yeah
in a fight oh straight up fight yeah
that's what i'm saying it's something in
boston when you were in boston
yeah with the ethiopians most guys talk
like that but cowan's really down yeah
foresees here's that rich kid anger
trying to improve himself
that richie rich anger oh you guys that
richie
you fighting like rich nothing to lose
he got nothing
yeah yeah uh what was dancing on the
dance floor
i appreciate you you and brian were
dancing yeah it was just you know being
silly were you throwing the back at him
nah he had this girl i had my girl at
the time you just said you start with
that he was like we was dancing on the
dance we
left brown was trying to like he was
doing his moves and stuff like that yeah
so i'm like i'm imitating
yeah we forgot about them we having fun
so when i forgot about
my ex ethiopian try to like slick and
talk to her i don't care you know i'm
dead boogie so i get back with her and
he goes
he tells me like hey bro that's my
sister you watch how you
treat my sister and then brian heard
that and brian's like
what and cuz i'm not talking to you i'm
talking to him that's my sister
and he was like dude i don't give a [ __ ]
like you know
i was like chill
yeah so it was like it was getting we
had like all kind of like yeah
you guys were your ass beat by those
ethiopians but i feel you i feel you
were they pretty big no we were thick
ethiopians aren't big no they were
skinny though yeah
you said they were bigger dudes no dudes
no the dudes we have got nothing to do
they said i'm the captain now
you can have her that's [ __ ]
before you go i already know what brenda
gonna say all right he's gonna go yeah
you ever heard of it
yeah you gotta look it up oh you gotta
are you you don't know what i'm talking
about okay you know what i'm saying
though he was a big deal in that movie
yeah
he was and you know but then he he
remember him and who was the other the
black girl crying saying they were
typing oh the girl
precious oh she was
she started complaining gabby yeah call
it gabby man yeah
i got typecast as the big fat black girl
it's like
isn't this guy in blood diamond 2 or
something uh no
it wasn't black blood diamond is a
different dude yeah i said blood diamond
two
that's what you say blood diamond two
like the movie two
or like as like as well like oh that
would be racist but he's not in
what that's a little racist he's in
blood timer right
nope he was in pirates of somalia right
yeah he's
using captain phillips catch christian
in the next uh hollywood
video wait i don't know it's gonna be
the next hollywood video
i told you yeah he was complaining
though after that
uh well he stopped recently and now he
goes there's a unique look
very unique look i go through his
lecture yeah
yeah he's go on
so yeah that little dude came up to me
in boston and it was like yo that that's
my sister
oh so you and brian were ready to fight
them no no i wasn't ready to fight
herself
thin people
there's a bunch of them i'm sure right
yeah it was like six smalling's like
mexicans there's never just one
that's true they all wrote due to the
club never no that's true
that's true they they they ride in the
game total that's a little racist
i mean
i don't think that's racist those are
those are facts
asians are good at math facts medicines
don't roll solo facts ages are good at
math
no they're not not not me all right
not always we got two they're not
they're not traditional they want
entertainment i feel like you can say
most asian sue if anything they sue
a lot of asians will sue okay sue
like legally oh for example like christ
yeah car accidents
oh that's oh that's like an asian thing
yeah that's kind of more of an asian
thing
like i was doing a heartbeat yeah like
oh you pushed me in the street
suing you i haven't heard that really
[Music]
you know you're scared now you're scared
to say it yeah i thought they'd be like
more jewish
like type of thing like that they would
sue more oh jules yeah
yeah i think everyone sues
it's like a big thing where if someone's
having a heart attack you don't help
them because they're going to sue you
once they're healthy again well that's
terrible
what yeah it's very common over in china
people sue you for the dumbest things
oh wait i've never heard it that's why
like no one will help anybody in china
because they're afraid they're going to
get sued
because it's happened so many times god
damn yeah would they be sued for
yes because uh they can say like oh uh
i've had complications
after this heart attack because he tried
to help me but he helped me right now
or like i mean we out here learning cpr
classes and [ __ ]
i just found out about the clear machine
so yo but uh
that's just like what you called it oh
no is it called the uh
i wasn't gonna [ __ ] it
that one made sense i got how you got
from a to b there
i've done that thank you thank you i
struggled i watched myself i wasn't but
because i was trying to make a point bro
did you always struggle with speech
yeah absolutely impediment oh really and
i mean you too
living i just found out i know right you
make a living
it's gotten better it's gotten way
better i've worked on it
in classes yeah when i first like when i
first met brian like
some of the words i'd say was my
references were just weird and brown's
like man i think you have a problem i'm
like really nobody's ever told me that
damn then i yeah i went i worked with
the teacher on it yeah
and then all that you know how i do all
the reading for like the reads and [ __ ]
yeah
like that helped help me out like doing
it so much like having a reader
i was like i was like you know yeah no
no it's it's basically gone now i still
struggle with certain words
but then also like uh when i had my tv
show on showtime the teleprompter
they'd have to get to me first like i'd
have to read through it oh
got it and then obviously you know i
would make fun of myself because like
like names for certain ufc fighters like
whether brazilian or chinese i'm like
their names are european they're a beast
and i would just call them by their
first name
but even now instead of dealing with i
just give them nicknames yeah wait so
did you
did you grow up with a speech i want to
do this defibrillator
defibrillator there you go yeah did you
grow up with a speech
i don't think so i just found out
he thought he was correct no but but i
think too so you probably weren't
introduced to a lot of the words dude
like like i didn't have a lot of those
words like
so like when once i met brian i started
reading way more just trying to keep up
so yeah so i started reading
like actual reading and uh like way more
tons of reading and then uh like you got
to power through some of the words there
where do you not want to try
well let's go ahead and look at what
books the books out
like man i bought all the weird waldos
man the ones without the picture
the ones without the pictures oh that
dude i could not [ __ ] i got horrible
sleep that's probably where my allergies
maybe it's a head cold
it feels like allergies but i got no
sleep saturday night dude
because i'm re i'm reading that night
stalker book and then i'm doing the book
or you just watched the show i well i
finished the book finally
but um i was on uh i don't
because i watched so much crime [ __ ]
thursday and i don't know if you guys
saw that black
uh suburban that would go around the
house had like that loud exhaust
and there's like all the there's like a
bunch of guys in the in the airbnb
the airbnb no i didn't want to scare
anybody i see it when we first got there
and they'd pull up and they'd like stare
through the window i'm like what the
[ __ ] are they doing
and then i was sleeping and i'm like i
bet they're case in the house which
means they're like trying to see what's
going on before they rob it right
and then fry i was like come back
tomorrow that's weird didn't come back
on friday
and i was like i'm tripping saturday
night when me and mark were up on the
deck chilling talking
that same thing loud exhaust comes down
stops in front of her house i didn't
hear it looks in
i told mark i'm like dog they came here
on thursday they're case in the house
he's like no who would rob us i'm like
people with guns
because we don't have guns and then they
kept circling the house
and then we all went to bed i'm like i'm
tripping maybe they live closer they're
doing a drug deal up the street
i'm asleep sleeping i hear the car
because you know my room was right next
to the street yeah
pull up they stop turn the engine off
and they start to get out
so i said because i knew mark was awake
it was like 3 30.
so i text mark i'm like yo dog you're
awake he's like yeah i'm like they're
here
and mark mark's gangsters also stupid
ass
within his underwear went outside and
they
took off mark didn't tell you this no
hell no he didn't tell me then he took a
picture
darius and justin you call me have them
on the way
yeah so i can't sleep all night wow wait
wait wait wait
whoa whoa whoa let's just back this is
trying to protect you mountain yeah but
again
i didn't hear anything i didn't hear
your name i was asleep okay
thank you for the protection but friday
night you know you said it came thursday
night
came through the first night they pulled
up right when we got there during like
en end of the day they pulled up did you
see what they looked like as you say
it was so dark but i could tell there's
a bunch of dudes in the car and then
they
left and i was like yeah that's weird
and then we came back at like one the
morning they came back around
weird and nothing happened so the
story's going nowhere
but i could that's why i couldn't sleep
there's probably some kids just messing
around
also that airbnb let's just talk about
it uh somebody's home there's somebody
home
they lived there they lived there they
had the family photos up and everything
that funniest photo
yeah their medication in the fridge
still yeah and also she had a
stethoscope lucky that one pink
stethoscope that's what i said um they
had a detoscope
and yeah i'll let you have that yeah
help me and then uh i was
jay and i was just going through a
medicine uh she won a lot of awards
she was looking at doctors well you were
going through her medicine it was right
i was staying in her room so basically
i'll stay in her office and she had like
her
award oh yeah you were like the officers
upstairs pretty much like
i saw the schematics of the house i saw
like the vacation and she
yeah she travels a lot so it's a good
family yeah but they lived there though
that was interesting i thought that was
probably them just checking on them nope
not them oh what do you got chin give
some crit events
all right
okay so a lot of people are upset that
anthony hopkins won best actor last
night let me guess they want chad
boseman to win
yeah yes and they found that it was
can't win
he passed away true people thought it
was weird because usually
this award isn't the very last award
that's presented
i think it's usually best uh picture
but this was the last one and then it
ended up it was so awkward
yeah they thought chad because the
academy doesn't know
they don't know they don't know what
they don't know who's gonna win to that
night like
that's the way it works so it's that
chad wind right off with a big sunset
anthony hawkins one did you see this
what the what movie
yes the father the father and what we
haven't even heard of chad was up for
ma rainey oh the one on netflix the one
netflix yeah
he did the one with viola davis yeah
that was a good film he killed it
my rainy is black bottom yes damn
anthony hopkins 83 older he is the
oldest winner
damn for best actor yeah how many how
many is this two for oscar in general i
believe
yeah he won for uh when he played uh
science of the lamps
yes okay so this is two right you guys
seen science williams right no
no yeah serial killer buffalo bill
no okay what can i do
you might be into it science of lamps
yeah i feel like it's a classic
actually you gotta watch you're a movie
nerd you would say i'm a movie
connoisseur yeah that's the lambs is
dope yeah i think you would like it
you you watch i don't really like stuff
like that you know like serial killer
[ __ ]
no you would not like my bookshelf
i showed cat my bookshelf i know didn't
you say you wanted uh
what was it what did you say hello
charles manson like
straight strand of hair that's one must
think about it
they say hello calories that's a great
movie man
yeah and then you were you were like red
dragon
and i forget the the third animal right
no wait
no there's hannibal there's ham so it
goes science the lambs
hannibal and red dragon but uh is there
another one no
there's three and then what but they're
out of order
hannibal right oh god oh that one
doesn't count oh hannibal right
man hundred yeah neither but the the
three main ones the same director i
think is
science and lambs hannibal and red
dragon yeah inside slams hand one red
dragon are
fire what's the red dragon about uh red
dragon is
another serial killer the guy who is
also in uh
um schindler's list the the nazi the
main knots and chandler's list
who's that guy you know what i'm talking
about great actor yeah he's german i
think
either way it's him and he's the serial
killer and hannibal lecter's
in prison and he's uh telling him what
to do
oh it's [ __ ] good man
who's that actor chin uh
damn chin just googled red dragon
i was like what's up all these red
dragons just francis dolahide
yeah great movie
all right well that's his actual acting
name and this is his real name
ralph finds oh wow oh oh
i haven't seen him oh he's a phenomenal
actor so a lot of people are upset that
uh
anything happens yeah a lot of people
were upset and we say a lot of people
twitter
yes okay i got you absolutely okay
what else you got okay so a 39 year old
japanese man got arrested recently
for scamming 35 women i didn't know this
was an
arrestable offense but what he did was
he began to
date 35 women and he would tell them
that his birthday
is on different day so he is constantly
receiving gifts throughout the year
so he would date a girl that he met
through work
and he works at a i believe a marketing
firm or something
uh he met a customer started dating and
he would tell her my birthday's in april
and then he'd meet another woman say my
birthday's in july
so he's constantly receiving gifts let
this man live no it says
the women give around a hundred thousand
in gifts or seven hundred six six
dollars
but imagine 766 dollars every
like what that's a yen 100 000 like
every week
from a woman no totally says in turn
these women gave them around a hundred
thousand yen
yeah a total of seven or six those
little gifts i wonder if that goes far
in japan or if that's
the equivalent of like just twenty
dollars i can't or you can get arrested
for that
i guess so i didn't even know about that
being stupid yeah
i didn't know that was like a arrestable
offense but people are saying that this
is a scam and so he was arrested i mean
there's bigger skills japan's also very
strict with stuff like that so good for
them
could be i mean i'd say let the homie
live man
i mean ain't nothing wrong with that
players gonna play man don't hate the
player hate the [ __ ] gifts huh yeah
them shitty gifts so what they're mad
they gave them
what they weren't spending that much
money but also those women take no
responsibility being stupid enough
yeah they just feel betrayed what else
you got jen
uh just showed you this earlier did you
know much about this american oak
that's my favorite really he was really
good he was a country singer and he was
on there because he was like
i'm doing this for my kid man because he
just had a baby yeah he's in this for my
kid man
and where i come from you know no one's
made it and then he didn't make
hollywood so i was like oh that's all
right man and then
i see this he was arrested
booked for burglary and second-degree
felony dude
because he wanted to see his kid that's
what he's saying oh
and he gave his kid from him yeah yeah
so when he enters the house that's
considered
you also hit her in the face yeah with
the palm strike
oh boss roon style yeah
not that boss hit women i'm saying is
the technique that he won a world
championship with
like he would he yeah he was hit with
his palm so he didn't want to break his
hands because he did uh bare knuckle
so hit with the palm wow because you
can't break your palm
it was pretty badass oh this kid is not
bad enough no no that is
boss yeah his career is over before it
even started really
oh he was all right he was just super
raw like he can't compete with the big
dogs
also no american idol last night because
the oscars thanks for that
oh yeah so like what
uh he's going through trial right now
no they said uh his bond is 15 000. he
was released on the same day
chin see if you think he can sing click
on it
is cecil rey she's talking about his kid
right she's doing great she just turned
two months four days ago
clearly not professionally trained no
but he has a nice he's raw
nice sound yeah so i think they're
thinking is oh if we get some actual
coaches behind him he might be something
and he said hold on let me hit my girl
in the face real quick
[Music]
i mean
not great hunting no but he has a nice
sound he's got he's got a raw
the wrong country guy they have on you
know you can only have one country guy
the country oh the beast the one that
you really really like yeah he's a
mullet he has a
he's almost too cool for the show he
feels like he doesn't give a [ __ ] he
wears a hat because he was a [ __ ] guy
wait is that the one that got out of the
because of the contract
no that's a different guy that guy's
white oh that guy is more old
yeah there's like a real country he's
only 16 writes his own music he's a
beast oh [ __ ] he's too good for that
show
oh all right
okay so a ring camera captured a
ups driver helping a child stuck
underneath the package
what the hell so i guess he delivered
this 95 pound package
and this little boy tried to drag it in
himself and help his mom
his mom was actually upstairs with his
two-year-old little sister she was
changing diapers
and suddenly the package just falls on
top of him he can't lift it up and he
gets stuck
the ups driver hears him screaming for
help runs back
and helps the little boy what the [ __ ]
should get delivered that's 97 pounds
oh he's all right no not yet not yet
oh
why is he yeah i think he was just
scared
the mom came downstairs with the uh baby
girl and was very
confused about what happened because she
saw that her like son was shaking up
then there's this ups
man with a package oh
yeah but everything for the work yeah he
did yeah he got that quick
the little dude was all right this is a
weird one
uh last year at the very beginning of
the pandemic there was
a guy named josh uh
what's his last name swain he went
online and he put out a notice saying
i am john swain i'm gonna go out of my
way to
tweet and dm every single man with the
name
john swain in the united states to see
who is
the josh swain and he eventually
created like this facebook group where
they all met in one
area in nebraska random green field it's
josh swain versus josh swain in a rock
paper scissors contest to see who is the
official winner gets the name
yeah and on top of that he said that
anybody named josh come to this field
and we're gonna duke it out
uh we're gonna fight with pool noodles
bring canned goods so we can donate to
the local food drive we're gonna donate
to
a um hospital and this is the cup
this is the outcome so this is the rock
paper scissors
it's the finals the rock paper scissors
to see who
is the official john everyone's name
there is josh
or yes josh not john just fight for a
different name
[Applause]
and then if you keep scrolling so that
was the official official person who
now has the name josh swain and
keep going keep going there are a bunch
of other this one
like this one there were a bunch of
josh's that came and basically fought
to see who the best josh was they went
with pool noodles
this reminds me of like role models you
remember at the end of role models when
they're doing larp
yeah live action role play yes and if
you keep scrolling down
you name a kid josh if you want to named
the official winner
oh my god i've never seen role models
they are they named the official winner
of the josh battle as this little boy
josh is five years old he got a burger
king guys but yeah this whole random
thing happened during the pandemic
because people were lonely and bored
uh they donated a bunch of money to a
local hospital in
omaha they donated to the food drive oh
so it was a charity thing
they they created it into a charity
thing oh gosh i thought they were just
doing it i was like damn
this is something my ex would have made
me go to
that's probably why it's your ex cat
hey yo they look like wait so he that
that little kid is the
he's the official winner of the name
ben the knee at josh they said that's
cool what else got you
this woman here was charged with a
fennel felony embezzlement for keeping a
vhs tape
sabrina the whatever teenager the
teenage wish and the cat
yeah yeah don't do can't you just pay
the final no she didn't even know
so it was like so she would actually
lose jobs and not know why
right because that phone honor of her
background if you do background check
let's show
felony embezzlement which sounds crazy
wait what did she do
yeah she was married to someone or she
was dating someone and i guess they
rented
this show for the kids and then the guy
didn't return it
so it just kept going on and on and on
if you don't pay for it remember we were
just talking about this not too long ago
but eventually you just own it and they
charge you i don't know yeah like in a
certain amount
so i didn't know that get charged on
your like uh
your record though well after a certain
like uh monetary amount if you don't pay
you have a warrant for your arrest
that's all he was saying would jackass
at blockbuster yeah
i don't think this is blockbuster though
i think this is a random like mom and
pop store yeah yeah that's who would
report it because blockbuster that's a
company i don't care about
but i heard that uh mom pop star
actually isn't even in business anymore
so if they went to court it's
like the town that she rented it from
versus her
not like the company they took it off
they took it off well she's good yeah
she's good now okay i mean
imagine all the jobs about she's
wondering like why am i not getting
hired yeah yeah
i'm overly qualified yeah yeah i get it
okay i saw this with elon musk saying
people will die traveling to mars
amount that he says it though is kind of
it's trippy i'll let you hear from he's
hosting saturday night live
yeah that's the other one to be able to
move off earth while we have the
opportunity everything we know is
right here and just because it's like
it's um it's not
it's a long journey you might not you
know come back alive
uh this hair plug game is good but it's
a glorious adventure and uh it'll used
to be bald you know that yeah
experience skinny and balding yes you
might just give me a cartwheel and
you probably won't have good food he's
chunky so
if if an arduous and dangerous
journey is a mullet or you may not come
back alive
he says it multiple times glorious
adventure sounds appealing
and you still have thousands of
volunteers if not millions of volunteers
yeah and then this part honestly a bunch
of people probably will die at the
beginning
over there a bunch of people probably
die in the beginning so why would you go
in the beginning
too it's like that yeah that's what
happens man that's why we're
here yeah you know how many people die
trying to discover america and other
[ __ ] countries yeah
yeah yeah that's gonna be hilarious
miley cyrus
too huh oh [ __ ] coming up
yeah and i saw this it's a sailfish we
talked about this before
almost killing this guy that scared me
that's adorable
it's still dangerous inside the boat
when it's moving around but that's so
close
are they shanking them after yeah
they're beating the ship you got it i
forgot
you know i know yeah someone actually
wrote in saying that
they have like an electronic thing
that's that shocks them and kills them
jesus christ yeah what a taser or
something something like that but for
fish
like in his brain i don't know what it
is
and it just automatically kills him you
should kill him right away
before i believe we had to bonk them but
when they're this big it's got to be
tough to kill him
oh yeah um
wait this is yours okay from before oh
yeah this was from last week
so uh lizzle made a tick tock video
saying that she was really drunk one day
and slid into captain america
chris evans dms and she didn't think she
was going to get a response back
and he ended up responding because i
guess she went online and apologized for
sliding in while she was drunk he said
that he's done more questionable things
on this platform than that which was his
dick pic getting leaked
and shortly after absolutely our boy
chet hank
says a piece of lizzo
he is all for black queens and a white
boy summer where's
uh his where's uh chet hanks hey this is
his story
yeah so he took us uh he reposted her
don't work
out captain america i'm here baby white
boy summer
black queen summer [ __ ] yeah gosh he's
great he's hilarious
all right um i saw this we were tagging
this a lot
this guy is incredible he is look how
big he is and how
athletic is and technical
you don't get it no damn oh [ __ ]
he's pretty damn good yeah that dude
look at him i know he's got good form
oh that's hot yeah that's phil bra
and i think that's pretty much it other
than okay there's some vin diesel stuff
what happened what happened i just saw
this i don't know what he's doing
exactly
does anyone plan this what he's doing he
said the last chapter yeah for fast nine
and that's his it's got to be his music
in the background why does he have a
mask on
his house yeah yeah it's actually not
too bad some of the stuff
that's not him singing no he comes in
that's his house does he live in the
safari
this doesn't make any sense he's just he
just made this video he doesn't explain
it
no he has a mask on at his own house
and that's a director of fast nine and
that's him being done
i think so
that's him that's got to be him has he
directed all of them that guy
no no no the more recent ones he has f
gary gray
yeah he did he did some the last one
i mean it just doesn't make any sense so
you're just walking around hell yeah and
then uh
the last thing what is his life just
wanted to quickly wish everyone
a happy birthday um
and we're celebrating of course by uh
another fast 10 story meeting
i don't get incredible director justin
taking in this beautiful earth right as
we're about to
commence working and that was it i want
to see
him i want to see his i'm responsible
video
he's not going to do it yeah i don't
think he counts because he's cuban
yeah i was oh he's cuban oh yeah where
is how did the tables get there if they
rode the bikes
that's what i'm worried about right now
everything is worried about this whole
thing i mean the whole thing is the [ __ ]
joe
it's just funny he says i trust he's not
black he's probably i think so yeah
there's a little bit
yeah that's what i thought he was i
thought he like was mixed
and his name is actually cuban oh it's
mark vincent's real name he says i truly
love our planet
and he was a break do you see when he
was a brake dancer when he was yeah he
used to be a breakdown skinny too he was
all skinny at hair
yep him and leonardo dicaprio both broke
oh i used to be pretty cancer
yeah he did uh leonardo dicaprio
you know that little uh dance break yeah
dude yeah
he used to be i think a popper
[Music]
you see that video ryan gosling getting
down on the disney
uh the disney kids thing oh yeah
him and justin timberlake and [ __ ] back
in the day
he was like getting it he's like doing
some moves he's bumping it
right there
god damn
[Music]
he's cute as [ __ ]
[Laughter]
[Music]
the hands
he can like traditionally dance he's
trained dancer like you saw him in that
uh one of my favorite movies that
the movie won all the awards uh
yeah i love that movie that one over uh
uh that won a ton of awards no moonlight
won over
la la land and they had that weird that
weird thing yeah battle but la la land
they won a ton of awards
this is why eva mendes yeah yeah right
yeah they still going strong
they are they got kids huh yeah yeah i
love doing uh the other guys
oh she's so good yeah she's so funny i
love her she's gators [ __ ] yeah
they don't play no [ __ ] is that it
that's it
all right man uh squad will be minus
chappelle lacy in lexington kentucky
next week thursday friday saturday
kentucky you're on the clock never been
uh let me know which
uh whiskey tours i should do houston
texas chappelle well being houston texas
houston texas plus special guests there
may 20th through the 22nd houston
improv then oklahoma city oklahoma
bricktown comedy club june 10th through
the 12th
get your tickets at fatkz.com
chappelle's head to philly
yep may 6th through the 8th helium
comedy club
tickets on sale right now may 13th
through the 15th raleigh north carolina
at good night's comedy club
take it to chapellacy.com that's it kid
love you [ __ ] bro thank you